[موسيقى]
سرينيفاس يبلغ من العمر 41 عامًا أحد الناجين من مرض كوفيد 19 وأخبره أطباؤه
أنه يواجه
مرضًا آخر يهدد الحياة
[موسيقى]
داء الفطر الأسود قد غزا
وجهه
وهو يستعد لجولة ثالثة من
الجراحة لإزالته قبل أن ينتشر
إلى دماغه
عانى 71 مريضًا آخر من هذه العدوى النادرة
في مستشفى سانت جون في بنغالور منذ
أبريل / نيسان
، وقد لوحظ ارتفاع في المرض في
جميع أنحاء الهند بين المرضى
الذين يعانون من مرض السكري بالفعل أو عندما
تسبب فيروس كورونا في الإصابة
بمرض السكري.
يشعر في جانب واحد من
وجهه وقد يفقد عينه بسبب الفطريات
التي أصابت ما يقرب
من 12000 هندي آخر بالفعل هذا
العام ، حيث يتقدم المرض
والعين تبدو سيئة للغاية ،
يكشف فحص التصوير المقطعي عن انتشار الفطر
في  هذه المرحلة
لمحاولة الجراحين
إنقاذ العين ولكن أيضًا
لتنظيف المنطقة المحيطة بالعين من
اللحم الميت لأن هذه الفطريات
يتغذى على اللحم الميت
والسكر ويحاولون منعه
من الدخول إلى دماغه
، لقد تكلف بالفعل حوالي ستة آلاف
دولار فقط لأن
ديونه الطبية للأدوية ستكون مدمرة لهذا
السائق ، فقد حصل على طفلين صغيرين
لدعمه يمر عبر الدم  الأوعية الدموية تؤدي إلى
تآكل العظام ودخلت أيضًا إلى
الجزء السفلي من الجيب من الخد ،
لذلك إذا لم يصاب بالأنثروبوسين ،
فماذا سيحدث سيستمر الفطر
في
الانتشار وسيدخل إلى الدماغ وسيبدأ في
ابتلاع جميع الأوعية الدموية
قد تكون الموجة الثانية داخل الدماغ في الهند قد تجاوزت ذروتها ،
لكن لا تزال موجات العناية المركزة مشغولة بمرضى كوفيد
الذين قد يواجهون الآن الفطريات السوداء أو ميركور
كمرض ثانوي
يحدق بنا بشكل صارخ في وجوهنا بعد الموجة الثانية
التي كانت بمثابة طفرة هائلة مقارنة بـ  كانت
الموجة
الأولى بالطبع هي
النقص الحاد في مادة الأمفوتيريسين ب مما أجبر
الأطباء على تحديد
من يحصل عليه ومن الذي قد يعيش ومن قد
لا يكون صعبًا للغاية ولكنه ليس
فقط  البالغون الذين يفتقرون إلى العقاقير المنقذة للحياة ،
تم قبول عشرات الأطفال في مستشفى قوس قزح في بنغالور بسبب متلازمة الالتهاب متعدد الأجهزة
أو
مرض غير مغطى يحدث
عندما ينقلب الجهاز المناعي للجسم
على نفسه ، أفضل علاج هو
عقار مستورد ومكلف
يسمى الغلوبولين المناعي الوريدي ivig
hardav samir في التاسعة من عمره ، تعافى من مرض كوفيد خفيف
، ثم هاجمت الأجسام المضادة أعضائه
بما في ذلك قلبه مما تسبب في سوء حالته ، وهو
الآن في تحسن ، وقد تحطموا تمامًا ،
إنه خائف جدًا جدًا ومخيف جدًا جدًا
لذا بينما في الهند  الموجة الثانية تراجعت
الخوف لا يزال يسيطر على العديد من
الهنود الذين يعتمدون الآن على الأدوية النادرة ،
قلة قليلة منهم يستطيعون تحمل تكلفة سام
كايلي سي إن إن بنغالور